i mentioned in the last video that 99
of the aromatic compounds that you'll
see in a chemistry organic chemistry
class is either going to be benzene or a
molecule derived from benzene
or a molecule derived from benzene so
what i want to do in this video is just
familiarize you with some of these
molecules and how to name them so you
know what you're looking at or i guess
so you can name what you're looking at
so you've seen this multiple times
benzene just looks like this it's a six
carbon ring with three double bonds
these three double bonds like that and
that's it's not its only configuration
sometimes it's shown to be in resonance
in resonance with this form right here
so the double bonds all flip around the
circle like that or sometimes it's
simply drawn like this and i just talked
about this in the last video just to
show that really neither of these
configurations is exactly right that
these pi electrons are just circular
they're just they're just moving around
the entire the entire ring so and
sometimes you'll just have the hexagon
with a circle on the inside to show that
the pi electrons just floating around
the entire ring now if i were to add
something to the benzene ring it's
pretty straightforward to name it so say
i have this molecule right here
this molecule right here
so let's say i have that that's benzene
but let's say this carbon over here it
has one two three bonds if i didn't draw
anything else you just assume that
there's also a hydrogen here but maybe
there's no hydrogen there maybe
let me do this in a different color
maybe you have a chlorine there well
this is just
chloro this is just chloro
chlorobenzene
chlorobenzene if that was a bromine it
would be bromobenzene so pretty
straightforward if let me draw it let me
actually let me change it a little bit
let's see had a chloro there and let's
say you had a
oh i don't know
let's say you had a bromo
over here
let's say you have a bromo over there
draw the bromo
bromo
so you could just start numbering you
could actually start numbering in either
place let's start with the bromine it's
just a it's alphabetically in front so
this would be one
bromo
one bromo
two chloro
benzene
pretty pretty straightforward now it
gets a little bit more involved the
iupac which we know is kind of the group
that named most things
they
tend to they everything else we've seen
so far they came up with a separate
naming mechanism from the common names
but benzene it's so ingrained in the
organic chemistry computing community
that all of the
benzene or benzene derivative molecules
they just kind of said well you know
what we're just going to use the names
that everyone uses so here's a couple of
common benzene derivatives so if you
have this molecule right here
let me
if you have this molecule right here
i'll actually draw the pi electrons as a
circle actually i'll draw it with the
double bonds so let's say you have this
molecule right here and over here you
have
an oh
you have an oh right there this is
called a phenol
this is called a phenol so it's not
called benzene anymore and if you had a
molecule that looked like this
if you had a molecule that looked like
this
so just like a phenol
so it's essentially it is a phenol
it is a phenol but let's say you have
a bromine right there what you do is you
start numbering at the the group that's
making this a phenol so you start
numbering there one and then you get to
the two so this is two bromo this is two
bromo
phenol
two bromo
fee
and unfortunately this is one of those
things that you just kind of have to
memorize that a phenol is really just a
benzene ring with an oh group another
one that is probably a good idea to
memorize i mean at least for me in
organic chemistry the most confusing
thing is when someone says the name of a
molecule that sounds like they expect
you to understand but you don't
understand it so it's i guess a good
idea to understand as many names as
possible
so if you just have a benzene ring and
you just have a methyl group
you just have a methyl group attached to
that benzene ring this is called
toluene
and once again if you had a
if you had a
let's say you had a
let's say you had a fluorine
right over there this would be one two
three fluoro
toluene i always have trouble saying
that because one two three you started
the group that's kind of making this the
toluene and so let me let me make it a
little bit clearer so this would be
three
fluoro fluoro toluene this would all be
in one word i just wrote it up here to
save some space
now a couple of other ones that you'll
see and once again as you know if you
watched many many khan academy videos i
hate memorizing things but these are
just names and these aren't
systematically derived the chemistry
community just uses them because that's
the way they've heard them so it is one
of those things you kind of have to
memorize so if you have a benzene ring
if you have a benzene ring
if you have a benzene ring where the
functional group that's kind of defining
the benzene ring
is it's essentially becoming an amine we
haven't actually covered videos on
amines yet and i'll do that in a future
video but it's essentially it's it's
replaced one of the hydrogens in ammonia
ammonia is n
let me draw ammonia ammonia has three
hydrogens
and
and one lone pair here we've replaced
one of the hydrogens actually there's
two hydrogens here we've replaced one of
the hydrogens with a benzene ring this
type of thing you call it aniline
and
aniline
and aleene right there in the same idea
if i put a fluoro here this would be
2-fluoroaniline so you use whatever the
base
molecule is and then you just name it
really the way we've named a lot of
things before and i'll just introduce
you to two more just so that you have
them under your belt so that you will
have seen them before if anyone
introduces them to you and they're
really introducing groups that we'll
study in more detail in the future but
if you have a benzene ring
once again
so we have a benzene ring
and then you have a carboxyl group and
we'll talk more about carboxyl groups in
the future but it creates carboxylic
acid this thing right here this hydrogen
it can actually be released quite easily
and we'll talk about that in the future
this right here is called benzoic acid
benzoic
acid and this name actually there is a
little bit
more logic to this you have the benz
part for the benzene so let me make this
in different colors the benzene part
that gives us the bends right there and
then in general whenever you have a part
whenever you have a
a carboxyl group like this it becomes a
carboxylic acid and you tend to add the
oic acid to the end so this actually has
some
logical naming to it now the last one
i'll introduce you to is very similar to
this instead of having an oh right here
we just have a hydrogen and we'd have it
would be an aldehyde so let me draw that
and you could almost imagine what that's
going to be called it's benz aldehydes
let me draw it
so you have your benzene ring
you have your benzene ring and then
instead of this carboxyl group you have
an aldehyde group
an aldehyde group you have your carbon
there's implicitly a carbon here let me
make that just in case it's the first
time you're seeing it you have a carbon
there instead of an o-h group you have
just a hydrogen and so once again you
have a benzene
so it actually makes sense to put the
bends over there and then you have the
aldehyde group and then you have an
aldehyde group right over here so this
is called a benzaldehyde or this
molecule is called benzaldehyde
benz aldehyde and we'll study we'll
study amines and aldehydes and
carboxylic acids in much more detail in
future videos and actually see reactions
that involve them but i just wanted to
expose you to this and when you see
these things so when you see these kinds
of names you don't you know become
intimidated